So to start off with the least exposure, your therapist will probably make you
hear the word snake and then move up to seeing the word snake and print, remind
you these two things might be switched and you may see it before you hear it,
but the fact is these are going to be very low on the list. Then your therapist
would make you imagine a snake. The next step up would probably be seeing a
picture of a snake in a terrarium. Then after that maybe seeing a picture of
somebody holding a snake. And then after that finally seeing a real snake, but
it's in a terrarium across the room. Then next, you might be ready to see
somebody actually holding the snake across the room. And finally, the most
exposure, would of course be holding the snake yourself.